a reading from Star Messenger Cosmic
perspectives on
civilization the seminal photo of planet
Earth rising over the lunar landscape
you know the one arrived in December
1968 from Apollo 8 the first mission
ever to leave home for another
destination from deep space the entire
Earth is is laid
bare as the cosmos intends you to see it
a fragile juxtaposition of land oceans
and
clouds isolated and a drift in the void
of space with no hint of anybody or
anything coming to rescue us from
ourselves this Outlook ascends a few
Realms higher than the overview effect
and represents the true beginnings of a
a cosmic
perspective Earth in the lunar sky is
nearly 14 times larger than the moon in
earth's sky Earth is also about 2 and 1
half times more reflective than the moon
although the exact value from moment to
moment varies with cloud cover so full
earth viewed from the Moon is at least
35 times brighter than full moon viewed
from Earth unlike what implied by NASA's
earthrise photo snapped from the
orbiting Apollo 8 Command Module Earth
neither Rises nor sets on the
moon viewed from the moon's near side
Earth never leaves the sky from the
moon's Far Side you might never know
earth existed at
all Apollo 8 did not land on the moon
which left him forgotten in the shadow
of Apollo 11's Neil Armstrong Buzz
aldron and Michael Collins instead
Apollo 8 just orbited the moon 10 times
before
returning yet no one had seen Earth so
distant
before their mission from launch to
splash down lasted from December 21st to
December
27th which closed out the bloodiest year
of the most turbulent decade in the
United States since the Civil War
a century
earlier during the Vietnam war more
Americans and Vietnamese died in
1968 than in any other
year a year that included the Tet
Offensive in February and the infamous
Meli massacre in
March back home now add the
assassinations of Martin Luther King Jr
in April and Bobby Kennedy in June
followed by persistent violent protests
in cities and on college
campuses some say Apollo 8 saved
1968 I prefer to say Apollo 8 salvaged
it notice that Apollo H Journey enclosed
the Christmas
holiday on Christmas Eve while still in
orbit around the moon the three
astronauts Bill Anders James level and
Frank Borman took turns reading the
first 10 verses of the Book of Genesis
from the King James version of the Bible
you may be familiar with some if not all
of those
lines Anders began we are now
approaching lunar sunrise and for all
the people back on Earth the crew of
Apollo 8 has a message that we'd like to
send
you in the beginning
God created the Heaven and the Earth and
the Earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of God moved upon the
face of the waters and God said let
there be light and there was light and
God saw the light that it was good and
divided the light from the
darkness
and God called the light day and the
Darkness he called night and the evening
and the morning with the first day and
God said let there be a firmament in the
midst of the waters and let it divide
the waters from the
waters and God made the firment and
divided the waters which were under the
firment the waters which were above the
and it was so and God called
the in the evening and the morning with
the second
day and God said let the waters under
the heaven be gathered together into one
place and let the dry land appear and it
was so and God called the dry land Earth
and the Gathering Together of the waters
called the
sea and God saw that it was
good and from the crew of
Apollo we close with good night good
luck a Merry Christmas and God bless all
of you all of you on The Good
Earth the cosmic perspective can do that
to you especially if you are
religious back on Earth in response to
this biblical reading beamed from the
Moon noted atheist meline Murray O'Hare
founder of the Ardent organization
American atheists sued the federal
government accusing it of violating the
First Amendment the part that says
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of
religion the suit was dismissed from all
levels of court to which it was
taken with no legal expertise I cannot
comment on the legitimacy of her lawsuit
but I have thoughts on the existence of
the lawsuit at
self at the time I was only 10 years old
but had the me of today met madalin of
then here's how that conversation would
have gone
down I'd ask her were you strapped to a
Saturn 5 rocket with 9 million PBS of
thrust and sent A4 Million Miles Away
into deep space to witness earthrise
from lunar orbit on Christmas
Eve
she'd reply
no I'd
say then shut the
up in that first of nine missions our
goal was to explore the moon but while
doing so we looked back over our
shoulders and discovered
Earth for the first
time after the Earth rice photo made its
rounds people Che
changed Earth the planet mattered as
never before thinking about Earth as a
holistic echosystem and not just your
section of it had not yet become a
priority or even a
thought just one of many Cosmic
perspectives in Star
Messenger
[Music]